every generation absorbs a world viw
they can't see beyond I think that's
what's going on with fine tuning now I
think future historians will look back
and think why did they just ignore this
fine Tunis why didn't they see it's
obviously evidence for Cosmic purpose
and the wonderful thing about the time
we're living in is we've got this little
thing called Baye theorem this little
bit of mathematics which tells us how
evidential support works I just think
we're in denial about it for cultural
reasons we're very well trained in the
west to be alert to religious biases
from a religious upbringing and that's
good what is not talked about very often
is secular biases I feel silly talking
about these things